[Música]
es un gusto saludarlos Soy Paula Jiménez
Correa y les doy la bienvenida Así es
Asia el magacín quincenal de France 24
que aborda las múltiples realidades de
este continente Estos son nuestros
titulares
luego de tres años de aislamiento por el
covid 19 ciudadanos chinos han empezado
a viajar el exterior luego de que el
gobierno pusiera fin a su política de
cero covid pero que ha implicado esta
reapertura tanto para el país como para
el mundo lo analizaremos en esta edición
cada vez es más evidente la
discriminación hacia las mujeres en
Afganistán recientemente el gobierno
talibán les prohibió asistir a las
universidades y trabajar en
organizaciones no gubernamentales
vivir sin inodoros esa es la realidad
para millones de ciudadanos indios que
se ven obligados a hacer sus necesidades
a cielo abierto aumentando los problemas
sanitarios
iniciamos nuestro recorrido por el
continente asiático en China que anunció
la reapertura de su fronteras tras poner
fin a la política de cero covid haciendo
que millones de ciudadanos empiecen a
viajar dentro y fuera del territorio
dando un respiro a la economía sin
embargo varios países han implementado
restricciones a Los viajeros chinos
debido a los crecientes casos del virus
que se vienen reportando ante esto la
Organización Mundial de la Salud ha
pedido al gobierno de chimpín
transparencia en la entrega de los datos
sobre contagiados y fallecidos pues
señala que no está dando cifras
completas del brote actual en el país lo
que imposibilita conocer el verdadero
alcance de la enfermedad incluso a nivel
mundial para analizar este tema hacemos
contacto con David Jana analista
internacional y experto en temas de
China quien vivió casi ocho años en
Beijing y Shanghai David Gracias por
aceptar esta invitación y empiezo por
preguntarle qué implica esta reapertura
de fronteras
Pablo un saludo muy especial para ti y
para todo el equipo de France 24 a toda
tu audiencia esas quizás la pregunta más
importante que representa Y qué tantos
beneficios trae esta reapertura de China
tenemos que hacer un pequeño recuento
desde el año 2020-2019 a finales cuando
se detecta el primer caso de covid y
China prácticamente se cierra el mundo
tengamos en cuenta que estamos hablando
de un país de mil cuatrocientos millones
de habitantes algunos le dicen la
fábrica del mundo y pues poder pensar en
términos comerciales como una fábrica
que se limita por falta de personal que
ha sido enviado a sus casas por el tema
del Coby 19 pues limita mucho la
capacidad de producción de china en
general el poder crear esta reapertura
no solo Pues con sus ciudadanos los
chinos pero con el mundo en general va a
poner una marcha superior más dinámica
al comercio quiero decir algo muy
importante Paola y es que la balanza
comercial entre China y Suramérica tiene
un valor alrededor de los 450 mil
millones de dólares eso fue en el 2021
Estoy seguro que en el pues no se ha
publicado la cifra oficial Pero estoy
seguro que llega a los quinientos mil
millones de dólares que va a representar
esto Pues que si va a haber una
reapertura va a haber más dinamismo y la
economía va a volver a ser mucho más
abierta Pues esta balanza comercial va a
tender a mejorar y el comercio entre el
continente suramericano y China va a
prosperar mucho más David Qué
consecuencias ha traído el fin de la
política de Cero covid en China correcto
Paola Pues de nuevo hagamos un pequeño
recuento de que venía sucediendo en los
últimos años cuando un ciudadano chino
por ejemplo con los que trabajo en
Colombia en otras partes del mundo
querían ir a China tenían que estar en
cuarentena entre 14 y 21 días en algunos
casos hasta más tiempo algunas veces los
gastos que estos ciudadanos tenían que
que pagar por estar en un hotel les toca
pagarlos a ellos mismos
los pasajes Pablo algo muy muy
importante habían pasado desde hasta
Diez mil dólares sí Entonces si tú haces
una un análisis de toda la connotación
que lleva ir a China durante estos
últimos tres años para un ciudadano
chino tiempo extenso de cuarentena
pasajes excesivamente costosos Acuérdate
que se limitaron los vuelos entonces
prácticamente los vuelos que había del
mundo hacia China o de China hacia
afuera eran vuelos charter Por decirlo
así prácticamente hacían los vuelos para
grupos de personas muy específicos muy
muy costosos y ahora pues eh que se abre
esta política de de cero covid se se
termina pues le va a permitir a los
ciudadanos chinos y o comunidad
internacional que tenga los permisos de
residencias demandados por el gobierno
chino para que puedan ingresar a China
con mayor fluidez con mayor tranquilidad
y evitar todos esos procesos tan
tediosos por último David podría
volverse a dar un confinamiento general
por el aumento de casos de covid 19 que
estamos viendo en este momento
Paula que la vuelva a imponer lo dudo
mucho sin embargo lo que tú dices del
del incremento de los casos de covid es
son cifras alarmantes en los cuales
tienen que tener muchísimo cuidado y un
punto muy específico Paula que veo que
muy pocos medios lo están hablando y que
bueno estar acá en France 24 para
decírselo a ustedes se aproxima el
movimiento masivo de seres humanos más
grandes del planeta que es el año nuevo
chino y se celebra a finales de este mes
a nivel mundial el movimiento masivo de
seres humanos se lleva a cabo en China a
finales del mes Qué representa esto un
reto muy muy grande que es el gobierno
chino no está preparado para controlar
eso va a ser un cóctel explosivo de Kobe
19 por decirlo así entonces va a ser un
reto muy muy grande que estoy seguro que
el gobierno está tomando todas las
medidas para controlarlo porque es que
le repito estoy hablando de mil
cuatrocientos millones de habitantes
Esos son los ciudadanos chinos hablamos
de ciudades como que tienen 25 millones
de habitantes Pekín 24 millones Entonces
si se avecina esta migración este
movimiento masivo de seres humanos tener
esta política tan estricta y prevenir
ese cóctel que te digo que puede
explotar y generar muchos casos de covid
19 va a ser muy muy importante
agradecemos a David Jana por su análisis
en otro tema 17 meses después de regreso
de los talibanes al poder en Afganistán
las mujeres tienen vetados la mayoría de
sus derechos al punto que human right
watch y la ONU han señalado que han sido
cercenados varios países de la comunidad
internacional han impuestos sanciones
económicas que agravan la crisis
humanitaria según ongs Samuel Salgado
nos cuenta más
imágenes que retratan el acontecimiento
que cambiaría radicalmente Afganistán
la retoma del poder de los talibanes en
agosto de 2021 ha significado un
retroceso para los derechos de las
mujeres a pesar de la promesa inicial de
moderación de los talibanes 17 meses
después el acceso a la educación
secundaria y interior está prohibido
para las afganas
compañeras de clase me informaron que
nos prohibieron la entrada a las
universidades lloré mucho
cuando salga el sol ya no habrá vida
para las mujeres en Afganistán ya que
los talibanes han cerrado todas esas
rutas hacia el éxito de las mujeres
cerrar la puerta de las escuelas y
universidades para las mujeres que son
la mitad de la sociedad significa que se
paraliza el proceso de evolución y
desarrollo humano en una sociedad
la participación en política y en cargos
públicos ya no es posible así como
trabajar en ongs el Ministerio de
asuntos de la mujer fue eliminado este
veto implica el cierre de los servicios
para la sobrevivientes de violencia o
para prevenir la explotación y el abuso
sexual Así mismo los hogares encabezados
por mujeres que constituyen casi una
cuarta parte de los hogares en
Afganistán no tienen A dónde acudir ni
apoyo para ganarse la vida
[Música]
las prohibiciones de los talibanes
también se inmiscuyen en la vida privada
las mujeres no pueden trabajar en casi
ningún oficio y se las limita a labores
domésticas el código de vestimenta es
estricto y obedece a la sharia ley
islámica que según los talibanes
justifica la supremacía de los hombres
incluso para movilizarse largas
distancias más de 78 kilómetros de
trayecto implica la compañía y
supervisión de un hombre estas medidas
que ongs califican como totalitarias y
misóginas provocaron manifestaciones en
kabul
seguimos a las calles a pedir nuestros
derechos y libertades y firmamos una
declaración
si los talibanes nos permiten y no nos
matan si Dios quiere leerán la
declaración
la comunidad internacional en cabeza de
Estados Unidos ha respondido
enérgicamente con sanciones económicas
sin embargo la ong acción el alambre
denunció que la población civil es la
mayor afectada con las sanciones que han
provocado una crisis humanitaria que
afecta más del 92% de los afganos
Nos dirigimos a India y ojo con esta
cifra según el Banco Mundial de los más
de 1.380 millones de habitantes que
tiene el país cerca de 207 millones no
tienen acceso a un baño y las
consecuencias son terribles
contaminación del agua enfermedades
transmitidas por el agua e incluso
violencia sexual en 2014 el Primer
Ministro narendra modi prometió
erradicar esta carencia de baños en el
país nueve años después los problemas
sanitarios empeoran
los 500 residentes de este pueblo
matussi Uruguay en utapadex tienen un
problema en común no tienen baños todas
las mañanas es una escena común aquí con
cubos en la mano la gente llega a este
pozo para buscar agua antes de ir a
hacer sus necesidades en los espacios
abiertos circundantes como camblesh hay
12 baños en el pueblo pero ninguno de
ellos está en condiciones de ser usado
muchos están sin terminar algunos no
tienen puertas algunos no tienen
asientos de inodoro algunos ni siquiera
tienen techos en tal estado como puede
alguien usarlos el 19% de la población
es decir poco más de 260 millones de
indios no tienen acceso a baños según
una encuesta del Ministerio de salud y
bienestar familiar publicada en 2022
aunque fue una de las promesas que hizo
el Primer Ministro en dramudy después de
ser elegido en 2014 el gobierno había
prometido construir más de 110 millones
de años en cinco años a un costo de 20
mil millones de dólares
en 2019 fue más allá y anunció que haría
que el país estuviera libre de defecar
al aire libre cada semana
visita este barrio marginal en el
sureste de Delhi para ver cómo están los
niños
encuentra al menos diez niños que sufren
de diarrea debido a la falta de baños el
principal problema aquí es la defecación
al aire libre Por eso hay muchas moscas
infestando su comida y su agua también
está contaminada por eso este niño está
enfermo
según la Organización Mundial de la
Salud más de 110,000 niños menores de 5
años mueren de diarrea cada año en India
la ausencia de baños no es solo un
problema de salud pública también
plantea la cuestión de seguridad
especialmente para las mujeres volvemos
a tapadesh y esta vez al pueblo camura
hogar de casi mil residentes pero no hay
ni un solo año
por ello las mujeres del pueblo se ven
obligadas a caminar dos kilómetros para
encontrar un lugar donde hacer sus
necesidades
nos enfrentamos a tantos problemas a
causa de ello las niñas no salen al
campo porque temen ser acosadas
sexualmente por los hombres
a mil kilómetros de la ciudad de pune
existe una idea innovadora para abordar
este tema construir un baño sobre ruedas
solo para mujeres lanzado en 2016
actualmente hay 12 de estos autobuses
que funcionan con donaciones a pesar de
tener la quinta economía más grande del
mundo el acceso a los baños sigue siendo
un desafío para
y para el cierre les dejo estos datos de
acuerdo con Sky tracks una organización
en Reino Unido que califica el
transporte aéreo internacional las
mejores tripulaciones de cabina del
mundo en 2022 fueron asiáticas en primer
lugar se sitúa Singapur Airlines de
Singapur le siguen Ana omnipone Héroes
de Japón garuda Indonesia de Indonesia
de Tailandia en el quinto lugar se ubica
Japón Airlines de Japón le sigue en
Qatar Héroes de Qatar hannan Airlines de
China aciana Ernest de Corea del Sur Eva
arte Taiwán y la lista la sierra catay
Pacific airways de Hong Kong
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
Los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
las redes sociales que aparecen en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web France 24 punto
com y no olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]